Arnold Opa Arnold we call him Chris
Pratt revealing his father-in-law Arnold
Schwarzenegger's sweet Grandpa nickname
yeah that's so nice the Marvel star has
two daughters Lila and Eloise with wife
Catherine Schwarzenegger Arnold's
daughter
when Chris spoke with E.T at the
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 New York
Premiere you share the special name his
kiddos call the Terminator star
Arnold Opa Arnold we call him oppa is a
common German term for a grandfather
Arnold is austrian-american and of
course a major action star I'll be back
so his praised for the final installment
of Chris's Marvel Trilogy goes a long
way we were gone
for quite a while
no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
last month Arnold tweeted his review of
the flick telling and Chris you crushed
it a Non-Stop perfect mix of comedy and
action I loved it and I'm very very
proud of you he came to the premiere
yeah he was so so nice to to give me
love and support on his social media and
he really liked the movie it was and
it's a great movie so I think he'd be
honest with me if he if he didn't like
it I don't think he would post that so I
think he liked it this is the last time
these Guardians of the Galaxy will be on
screen together this is volume three
it's very intentionally a Trilogy and
this is the end James really wanted me
to do well with the screen test because
he wanted me but we had to convince
people at Marvel or he had to be at
marble uh to uh to hire me so he really
wanted me to do a good job and
apparently at the screen test I was not
doing the best job but thankfully he
brought in Dave Batista and he and I got
to riff a little bit and get on camera
and that was just enough to seal the
deal so I got the job
[Music]
foreign